so I can start a YouTube channel and
like one of the questions I wanted to
ask you was like I'm having trouble like
finding a niche because like I like do
so much [__] like obviously I played
football I don't think I don't think you
need to find a niche I think your Niche
is that you are that human being yeah
yeah your Niche is you the human yeah
and everyone's like I need a niche which
actually means I need to stay narrow in
something and just talk about football
yeah
yeah that's the reverse you need to be
as broad as possible but fully you which
becomes your Niche that's me yeah I talk
about you know the Jets I talk about
sports cards I talk about wine I talk
about business right yeah like I'm not a
niche I'm broad as [__] yeah my Niche is
that I'm Gary yeah
that's your [__] Niche your Niche is
you the human everyone's holding back
their full self and then they're like
okay I'm only showing people three parts
of me and I gotta pick one so they go
this narrow instead of being that